let's get to quarterback word
association and let's begin in texas in
houston
deshawn watson
first word or phrase you're not limited
to one
word phrase clause paragraph that comes
to mind as it relates to the
relationship between desean watson
and the houston texans
i think it's broken mike that's the word
that first comes to mind i mean
texas are still insistent of we are not
trading deshaun watson he will see the
lie today he will come back to us just
wait just wait even though they haven't
talked to him they haven't had a word
with them they haven't new coach david
culley has not exchanged any words with
deshaun watson but they are convinced
they can talk him into coming back that
he will come back just because he has no
other options and i don't know that
that's going to be the case i think they
wait too long on this to me you have to
get it done by the draft to get full
benefit out of it
well there's going to be an all season
program so he's not around you still
think you can talk him back right so
until training camp when he doesn't show
up for training camp and you figure out
oh my gosh we need a quarterback who are
we going to have start at quarterback if
deshawn watson truly doesn't come back
and i don't see him coming back so i
think there's a broken relationship and
i don't think the texans yet realize
that it's broken mike
this is going to take a little bit of a
wind up and it may not be worth the
payoff but when you said i think it's
broken it reminded me
of one of the lines from my cousin
vinnie when he says i think the
effing thing is broken
and and that's relevant because there's
the thing going around on twitter now
where
they say cite a line from a movie that
fans of it would instantly recognize and
i don't know what my cousin vinnie fans
recognize i think the effing thing is
broken and now i'm sitting here houston
we have a problem
i'm pondering the possibility of saying
the word because we're not on nbcsn
today
uh and we're on peacock and let me tell
you i've watched many of the offerings
on peacock and the f word is rampant on
peacock i want to start a petition to
use the f word on the days that we are
peacock only pete can i go ahead and let
it fly today just for fun pete
pete says pete says let's wait pete pete
has kids to feed so in deference to the
children of pete who already have it
hard enough because he's their dad i'll
make sure that they also don't go hungry
all right um
i i think that my phrase would be cut
off the nose to spite the face that's
what the texans are poised to do because
they want to send a message because they
don't want to blink because the inmates
can't be running
the prison
one of the catchphrases
regretful catch phrases from the
franchise from a few years ago i we've
talked about this before sharing on
pftpm and i'm on board they are going to
screw this up they are going to dig in
and they're going to hold firm and
they're going to blow their opportunity
and nick casario is going to talk
himself blue in the face to get jack
easter being cow mcnair to understand
how
they need to set aside the desire to
send a message or win this weird tug of
war and just maximize the return you
don't maximize the return by ignoring
opportunities to maximize the return
which is seemingly what they're doing
well and mike here's the deal desean
watson had one of the great years
a quarterback has had this year they led
the league in passing yards they won
four games this is a team that is a long
long long way away from contending with
or without desean watson and it may be
time to just hit that hard reset button
and start over and get all the draft
picks you can get because you would get
a ton and they've traded all those away
they don't have as we know a first round
draft pick this year so hit the hard
reset button and start over and and i
know franchise quarterback i get it
franchise quarterbacks don't come along
like this
you're not close to contending anyway
you don't have the draft picks to do it
you don't have the cap room to do it so
are you just going to let
deshawn watson play out his deal and and
lose for the next four year i just
i don't know i don't know where this
franchise go it's in disarray and it's
in disarray for a reason
it reminds me a little bit although it's
a different position it reminds me of
what the vikings went through six years
ago with mike zimmer and rick spielman
came to houston
to meet with peterson and to gently
point out to him you play for us or you
play for no one it's easier to do that
with a non non-quarterback you need your
quarterback to be all in your
quarterback is a member of management
among the employees who is there to lead
to inspire to hold accountable he has to
be fully on board there's stuff he does
that goes above and beyond what he's
paid and if he doesn't want to be there
now
if deshawn watson shows up i don't think
he does anything half-assed
but
i just i just don't think he's going to
show up and i think he's made it clear
to them he's not going to show up
and i i they just they need to they just
need to move on and uh we need to move
on to the next team russell wilson and
the seahawks shireen word association
for the current relationship between
wilson and seattle
i think it's uncertain mike and maybe
hanging on by a thread because
it sounds like to me that wilson perhaps
wants more than what the seahawks can
deliver and and that's the question
are they going to do
what russell wilson wants them to do and
if they don't then this relationship is
short-lived i can very well see him
playing this season for the seahawks and
that being the end of his career in
seattle and this is just a different day
and age of quarterbacks mike we used to
see them go to one team they'd be
drafted by that team and they'd finish
their career there that's not the way it
works anymore and we're seeing
quarterbacks with a lot of power and
they're exercising that power and that's
exactly what russell wilson is doing
mike
fear is a great motivator as i learned
through 12 years of catholic school and
fear of alienating the fan base used to
be the primary motivation when it came
to quarterbacks who may have wanted out
but didn't want to say anything didn't
want to do anything that could
potentially make the fans upset we are
seeing quarterbacks at a point where
they don't care anymore that they trust
that the people who get it
will be with them and the ones who don't
understand it if they're not with them
fine and you know what
maybe this is a reflection of
social media maybe this could it be
there's something positive about social
media in that we all kind of thicken our
skins and recognize not everyone's going
to like us there's going to be people
who don't like us there's going to be
people who like us and if you don't like
me if you don't like my decision if you
don't like that i don't want to work
here or live here or play for this team
that's your problem not my problem i'm
going to go forward with my life and i
feel like that's what sean watson's
doing and i feel like that's what
russell wilson is thinking about doing
me for me i'll go one word fluid because
that's the truth that was the last word
i got last week where does it stand is
he asked for a trade he hasn't asked for
a trade all things are fluid we haven't
heard anything more about where that
fluid has flowed the past few days maybe
things are calming down a little bit
maybe they've reached some sort of a
quiet understanding but it was fluid as
of last week and i think it's currently
fluid between russell wilson and the
seahawks stay in the nfc west the san
francisco 49ers jimmy garoppolo best
word phrase clause to describe the
relationship between san francisco and
its supposed franchise quarterback
well i'm going to steal this one for
pete but it does feel like it's it's a
one more chance and it does feel like
that jimmy garoppolo is going to return
to the 49ers this year and be their
quarterback but perhaps it will be his
last year there and it does almost feel
like a one-sided relationship like jimmy
wants to be there because he thinks he
can win there he's shown he can win
there i mean they should have won the
super bowl last year and the 49ers keep
having their eye looking elsewhere to
where can we upgrade and they obviously
should have gone out and gotten tom
brady and they might have been the ones
lifting the lombardi trophy this year
they didn't do that they stuck with
jimmy g i could see this playing out for
one more year mike but if they don't get
back to the super bowl i see this is
really a short-term relationship
i'll go with lack of pliability because
that sums up jimmy garoppolo and his
inability to stay healthy at a time when
43 year old tom brady continues to show
up for every game 23 games missed by
garoppolo over the last three seasons
i've been thinking about this one a lot
i need to write something about it i
need to collect my thoughts need to
really really articulate
what what's rattling around inside my
brain i think they're going to cut him
i think they're eventually going to cut
him i think that's going to happen
between now and week one there's no
guaranteed money left in the deal
there's a
ridiculously low salary cap charge
relative to the cap even if it drops to
180. he's got a 25 million dollar
compensation package i think a half
million is tied up in off-season
workouts
uh the rest of it is a salary of 24 1 24
2. i think he's got a half million in
workouts 300 000 in per game roster
bonuses and uh like a like a whatever
the difference is 24-2 salary i i don't
think they're gonna find anyone to trade
for him i don't think that for the same
reasons the 49ers want to move on
another team is not going to want to
take that contract because of the
inability to stay healthy the patriots
make a ton of sense from a trade
standpoint
they're not going to pay him
they're not going to pay a year after
paying cam newton 7 not even 7 million
the maximum i think he ended up making
3.7 million on the year with the salary
and the incentives i don't think anyone
is going to take on that contract i
think the 49ers are going to get someone
else whether they trade for sam darnold
whether they draft someone whether they
sign someone they're going to hold on to
jimmy garoppolo until they get his
replacement and then they're going to
cut him that's my prediction for the
49ers in garoppolo this off season
and you think is darnold the best option
that's what you think they're going to
do
i i peter king and i are miles and eyes
some point over the past day i can't
keep it straight anymore because we talk
so much about these different angles but
i i think that that darnold would make
sense i was it was miles and i last
night trying to figure out when darnold
would be traded before the draft after
the draft during the draft after round
one like josh rosen was traded by the
cardinals to the dolphins a couple of
years ago i think darnold is a guy that
could run that offense
and
kyle shannon is very particular about
the way he wants it to be run and i
think he believes that darnold can do
exactly
what what is expected in that offense or
i don't know maybe they trade for kirk
cousins although i don't see the vikings
letting him go uh but i my prediction
write it down now and if i'm wrong oh
hey i was right about the super bowl
winner so i have some leeway here jimmy
garoppolo cut by the 49ers before week
one derek carr and the raiders
word association to describe the
relationship sharing
in lust but not in love and i think this
is sort of the same
same scenario we've talked about my i
think the the raiders really have that
wandering eye looking around to what's
better that's out there you know how can
we upgrade over this guy and and derek
carr thinks he can win with the raiders
and so i don't know how this
relationship ends i don't think there it
is
there it is i think that
i think that maybe it doesn't end well
for for either side but you know derek
carr may be their best option right now
i don't know who they upgrade
over uh derek carr at this point mike
but i certainly don't think they're in
love with derek carr
i think can we put that back up because
it's not it's not entirely accurate the
way that we have that because marcus
mariota is the backup quarterback
they're talking about trading him i
think we changed the the the person on
the left to
any other quarterback that's what it is
with john gruden
any other quarterback that's what he
does and chris sims has told us that's
how he is and he's so smitten with the
idea of eventually getting himself a
peyton manning well there isn't a peyton
manning out there there isn't a guy
that's going to fall into john gruden's
lap
but
yeah hey the points bet odds last week
when everything started to bubble up
with russell wilson top of the list las
vegas raiders right so
gruden's going to look gruden's going to
think gruden's going to meander gruden's
going to ponder i was told a couple of
weeks ago when the possibility of a
trade first came up that gruden is not
trading him i haven't written that yet
at pft because i don't believe it
because i still think there's a chance
that somebody's going to fall into
gruden's lap and he's going to say derek
carr see you later jalen hurts eagles
word association relationship go
i think honeymoon they're still in that
honeymoon phase mike and we know hertz
is taking his receivers into texas i
assume down in the houston area where he
is from to work out with those receivers
he's the quarterback and he's going to
be the quarterback of the eagles this
season but
who knows how that's going to work out
right because they're still in that
honeymoon phase trying to figure each
other out is he the right guy for the
eagles is are the eagles the right team
for him and that's yet to be determined
so
new coaching staff new offense a lot of
new in in philadelphia including the new
starting quarterback who only started a
handful of games last season so a lot to
be learned by this team this year
for me it's dangerous expectations and i
really do think one of the reasons why
jalen hurts was removed for nate sudfeld
from the week 17 primetime game on nbc
between washington and philadelphia was
because if hertz had pulled it out it
would be a given then that he's the guy
and it builds this legend and you don't
want
you don't want the expectation of the
fan base going into jalen hurts what
will be his first full season as the
starter being
just too much we
this isn't going to be an mvp candidate
right out of the gates it's going to
take some time it's going to take some
effort oh by the way they fired doug
peterson which sets everything back i
just think they don't want the
expectations for jalen hurts to be too
high that's where the danger creeps in
and that's where you end up having
eagles fans shift their ire from carson
wentz over to jalen hurts if he doesn't
perform at the level that they would
like alex smith
washington
what's the word association to best
describe that relationship shireen
this is a really hard one mike and i i
guess cozy i would use the term cozy
because you know washington really likes
alex smith and and what he did the story
for the ages and it's probably going to
be made into a movie and you root for
that and that's fantastic he won
comeback player of the year but at the
same time you know they they want an
upgrade at quarterback they don't know
who their quarterback is going to be
they they put in for matthew stafford
they they talked about that you know
kyle allen could come back they've
already resigned taylor heinke so you
know i don't know what they're going to
do at quarterback we don't know what
alex smith's future is you root for a
guy like that i know washington is
rooting for him uh but i'm not sure that
he's their quarterback long term i'm not
even sure he's their quarterback this
year it's not going to surprise me at
all if he retires after what he did last
year
yeah i'm trying to think of the best way
to put it it it's just it's over i feel
like it's over
he's got a huge salary for 2021 it's not
guaranteed they've paid him a lot of
money over the last three years remember
when they traded for him bruce allen
instantly gave him a contract extension
didn't have to and in hindsight
shouldn't have done it but i just think
that
for what he's due to make for what
they'd want him to take he's better off
getting cut which is what will happen
and just picking his next spot picking
where he wants to be a backup and you
can make very good money as a backup
quarterback in the nfl four five six
seven million it's a great gig if you
don't have to play and i think alex
smith has a lot to give by way of
teaching and mentoring a young
quarterback and he can almost slide into
a josh mccown phase of his career where
he doesn't play but he's on the team he
gets compensated more than he would get
compensated as a quarterbacks coach and
uh maybe at some point makes the
transition to coaching if that's what he
wants to do but alex smith has always
been a guy about whom the other
quarterbacks on the team have raved go
back to 2017 2018 with patrick mahomes
all the credit that alex smith for being
selfless and teaching and helping
mahomes learn that offense that's what
smith can do
and i think that's what we'll see him do
wouldn't it be something if he went back
to the chiefs at the back up to patrick
mahomes that that
i'd take alex smith over chad henny and
matt moore all due respect to those two
so i just think it's over in washington
aaron rodgers
we thought it may be on the way to being
over based upon the things aaron rodgers
said after the nfc championship how
would you best describe the current
relationship between player and team in
green bay shireen
i think they're the old married couple
right they're bickering and
kind of looking elsewhere and they've
been together so long and you know they
they know how each other did you wash
this pair did you wash this pair
i washed it go ahead
exactly yeah so they're the old married
couple there that are just kind of
getting along in life and whatever the
rest of the
life brings that's what it's going to
bring but i i don't know how long this
relationship lasts mike you know i again
i think if aaron rodgers wasn't coming
off the mvp season we're having a
different conversation and we're talking
about aaron rodgers going somewhere else
we're talking about him being traded
somewhere else but you can't do that
coming off an mvp season and that's what
happened so he's their quarterback for
this season beyond this season who knows
i mean i think they drafted uh jordan
love to be their quarterback in the
future i don't think they drafted him to
groom and eventually trade i think they
drafted him with the thought of he's
going to replace aaron rodgers so i
still think that's going to happen it's
just a matter of when mike
well and to take your excellent example
one step farther and ruin it completely
they are the old married couple where
one holds power of attorney and is
waiting for the other one to slip into a
coma so the plug can be pulled that's
what it is that's what the pa i mean of
course the packers aren't going to trade
aaron rodgers now he's coming off an mvp
year and if he continues to play at that
level they won't trade him or cut him
after 2021. that's the core issue here
rogers wants certainty he wants
commitment he wants to know that plug's
not getting pulled for the next two or
three years a contract with an
appropriate level of guaranteed money
ties the team's hands the team and when
when
brian goodacoon said he's under contract
that's code for we hold the cards well
he's under contract we hold the cards we
have him under contract for three more
years we get to decide this year do we
want him back yes we do next year do we
want him back we'll see the year after
that we'll see that's what aaron rodgers
wants to avoid because they have that
ability to just say see you later
whenever they want so i think that's
good you're part of it was good i i made
it dark and disturbing but it's accurate
the packers are just waiting for the
moment to pull the plug on aaron rodgers
tuatanga by loa and the miami dolphins
how would you describe their
relationship
i would say they're dating but not yet
committed mike this is just kind of that
early phase of
uh or is this going to be a long-term
relationship or a short-term
relationship i just don't think we saw
enough from tua last year to know what
he is to know how good he can be and the
problem for the dolphins obviously is we
did see enough of justin herbert to know
that he's going to be a great
quarterback i think everyone agrees on
that and dolphins bypass justin herbert
to take to us so
uh
this they need to get
brian fitzpatrick re-signed or something
because to a might or not might not be
the quarterback of the future for the
dolphins now i know ryan fitzpatrick is
not the quarterback of the future but
that relationship certainly worked well
for the dolphins this year
we asked to a couple of weeks ago
pointed question do you want ryan
fitzpatrick back next year and he did
not
answer the question he gave us an answer
it was friendly it was nice
when you look at what he said he didn't
answer the question okay to take another
excellent
selection by you and just completely
throw it off the rails
this is this is the pete's very nervous
now
dating but not yet committed with this
caveat
tua is is the guy they take to dinner
but then
when they get home they grab the phone
and text someone else you up
so
that's that's the that's the
relationship between now ryan
fitzpatrick is moving out of town so
they're going to need somebody else to
text you up after midnight too but
that's the relationship between tua and
the dolphins for right now
two has basically got to prove that he's
the one worthy of getting that post
midnight text message from the dolphins
ben roethlisberger and the steelers how
would you describe their relationship
i think it's just comfortable mike
they've gotten to that point where it's
hard to break up right you're just kind
of they're both there and
there's probably better options out
there for a team that has a great
defense and some excellent weapons on
offense but it's just comfortable with
ben at quarterback and
that just if he comes back then they're
gonna have him at quarterback as long as
he's gonna be the quarterback we talked
about how the quarterback dynamics have
changed pittsburgh is one place that
hasn't changed i don't see ben
roethlisberger going anywhere else to
finish his career i think it's in
pittsburgh i think he finishes his
career in pittsburgh and walks away as
one of the league's all-time leading
passers is going into the hall of fame
and and will not play for another
franchise that's how i see that that
relationship finishing
this to me is the football equivalent of
staying together for the kids
i don't think either side wants to be
perceived as the villain in the divorce
the steelers oh we want him for another
year ben oh i want to play for another
year i think any time you start talking
about that final year
you're just asking for trouble and i'm
i'm tainted by the brett favre of 2010
experience with the vikings when he came
back for one more year although from
roethlisberger's perspective jerome
bettis came back for that one more year
and it worked out the steelers aren't
nearly as close to winning a
championship now as they were going into
the 2005 season that was the season
after they were 15-1 in roethlisberger's
rookie year and lost at home to the
patriots in the afc championship the
next year they cashed in and they won
the super bowl they're not they're they
got the ravens they've got the chiefs
they've got great teams in that
conference that they have to deal with
they got great teams in their division
they have to deal with so i i just think
that and i still think there's a chance
that it's going to fall apart ed
bouchette planted this idea in my brain
a couple of weeks ago he had an
excellent item in the athletic just
because everyone has said all the right
things publicly it does not mean they're
going to work out a contract that allows
ben rothersberger to return and they
clear up 19 million dollars just like
that in cap space if they cut ben
roethlisberger jameis winston saints how
would you describe that relationship
close to proposing uh they're thinking
about it they bought the ring it's just
when's that right time gonna be to to
make that full commitment toward
marriage and i do think this is headed
that way mike now whether jameis winston
ends up starting the season as a
quarterback i don't know i think sean
payton finds some way to use both taysom
hill and jameis winston but i do see
jameis winston with the saints and i do
see jameis watson playing for the saints
as well as taysom hill and how that
works out i don't know i don't know that
it's going to be a roger stahlbach craig
morton hey let's alternate plays or
let's alternate series but i think both
of those guys play quarterback for the
saints this year
i i feel like and i think back to the
sean payton interviews that he did super
bowl week he was on with us he was on
with several others and the way he talks
about jameis winston
i i feel like
he's the guy in the local courthouse
square with the megaphone saying
i'm getting ready to propose
if anyone else out there would like to
do so first please feel free but i'm
getting ready to and i feel like he he
believes he owes it to jameis winston to
help place him in a starting job
somewhere i'm not 100 sure he wants him
because if he did
i don't know why he'd be saying publicly
all the things he's saying because
winston is on track to be a free agent
they're not going to use the franchise
tag on it they don't have a right of
first refusal in his contract so
all of these flowery things that he said
about what a great leader he was and
this the other thing
the other teams out there that are
identifying their free agency options oh
hey
the bears we talked about them earlier
hey maybe i should go get jameis winston
so i feel like i feel like what sean
payton is trying to do is set up
someone to come take him and he can say
oh boy we really wanted to keep james
winston let's move on to take some hill
and find
someone else to back up taste some hill
and on that note a guy who was one of
the backups in new orleans until he left
last year for the carolina panthers the
last one on our list teddy bridgewater
and the panthers how would you describe
their relationship
feels like a fling mike kind of a
one-year fling right we had a lot of fun
we won some games
all right that's it uh
be here's the door see you later
might see you again sometime but we're
we're moving on to somebody else so
that's what it feels like to me this
just doesn't feel like it's gonna work
long term i don't know where teddy ends
up maybe he stays there but they
certainly might want a better
quarterback than what they got from
teddy bridgewater this season
i hate to admit this
publicly and nobody's really watching
today but uh so i'll go ahead and say it
i love the movie grease there's just
something about and i shouldn't there is
just something about it that is so
awesome and and pete pete said summer
love when you said fling and i think of
the scene and and i'm gonna admit way
too much knowledge of this movie but the
scene at the pep rally and the bonfire
when all of a sudden danny and sandy get
together again and danny acts like he
doesn't know her that's the panthers
right now with teddy bridgewater that's
that scene
and teddy is is uh
olivia newton john and and and teddy's
getting upset and teddy is getting ready
to say to the panthers i wish i'd never
laid eyes on you and run away because
it's clear shireen they don't want him
the report came out they offered him to
the lions for matthew stafford along
with the eighth overall pick in the
draft plus more and the lions said no
thank you so it's a shame and i'd love
to see teddy bridgewater back in
minnesota um
i i but uh
i don't think that's gonna happen either
but but i thought teddy was good last
year i don't get it i think david tepper
the owner of that team is so desperate
to get a true franchise quarterback he's
willing to throw overboard any other
quarterback as they try to get a
franchise guy and i put them in play for
something behind the scenes to try to
get to sean watson or russell wilson
yeah well i was going to say deshaun
watson makes sense certainly he played
at clemson a huge draw for for the
panthers he'd answered their prayers at
as the franchise quarterback something
really have they even had that in in
carolina i can't think of a great truly
franchise guy that they've had one of
the best well i guess cam cam won the
mvp award in 2015 when they went 15-1
but
he he would be the the next thing from
cam right as their as their franchise
quarterback but the question would be
would desean want to go back and play
there he does have the no trade clause
but it from carolina's standpoint it
makes perfect sense that they would be
all in on deshaun watson and let's go
get him and we'll even trade you
christian mccaffrey what do you want
we'll give it up to get desean watson
mike
um
and
i had a thought
as as you were as you were saying that
clemson
clemson
they have the eighth overall pick
the jaguars have the first overall pick
two teams that entered the league
together back in 1995. not that has any
relevance to this but
i feel like david tepper is so
determined to get a franchise
quarterback russell wilson
eighth overall pick
plus straight up a lot of other stuff to
go get
trevor lawrence with the first overall
pick in the draft and uh when when i
think back to the all or nothing series
that focused on the panthers and david
tepper was riding in the back of an suv
and he was talking about how the league
is set up for all teams to be 500 and
there are certain things you can do to
skew above or below it
coach
gm and you got to have a great
quarterback and i remember thinking in
that moment ron rivera's done marty
herney's done
and david tepper is going to be
hell-bent on getting a franchise
quarterback so uh clearly bridgewater is
going to unload him as part of a trade
if they can
but maybe that maybe they if they can't
get a proven veteran who's available and
is a true franchise quarterback maybe
they make a run to the top of the draft
and keep trevor lawrence in the
carolinas moving forward to start his
nfl career
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports